you describe an idea lab as uh being
opposite of echo Chambers so we know
what Echo Chambers are and you said like
just basically no good term for the
opposite of an echo chamber so what's an
idea lab yeah well first of all both of
these we think of an echo chamber as
like a group maybe or even a place but
it's it's a culture it's an intellectual
culture yeah
and this goes along with the high run
low so high rung and low wrong thinking
is individual so I was talking about
what's going on in your head but this is
very connected to the Social Scene
around us and so groups will do high
rung and low rung thinking together
um basically it's collect so an echo
chamber to me is a collaborative low
rung thinking it is it's a culture where
the cool it it's based around a sacred
set of ideas and it's the coolest thing
you can do in an echo chamber culture is
talk about how great the sacred ideas
are and how bad and evil and stupid and
wrong the
people are who have the other views and
this and and and and it's it's quite
boring you know it's quite boring
because you know it's very hard to learn
and changing your mind is not cool in an
echo chamber culture it makes you seem
wishy-washy it makes you seem
um like you know uh like you're waffling
and you're flip-flopping or whatever it
showing conviction about the sacred
ideas in necro chamber culture is
awesome if you're just like you know
obviously this it makes you seem smart
while being you know humble makes you
seem dumb so now flip all of those
things on their heads and you have an
you have the opposite which is ideal lab
culture which is collaborative High
wrong thinking it's collaborative truth
finding um but it's also just it's just
a totally different vibe it's uh it's a
place where arguing is a fun thing it's
not no one's getting offended and and
criticizing like the thing everyone
believes is actually it makes you seem
like interesting like oh really like why
why do you think we're all wrong and
um expressing too much conviction makes
people lose trust in you doesn't make
you seem smart it makes you seem stupid
if you don't really know what you're
talking about but you're acting like you
do I really like this diagram of where
on the x-axis agreement on the y-axis is
decency that's in an idea lab in an echo
chamber there's only one axis it's uh
[__] to non-ass hole right this is a
really important thing to understand
about the difference between you call it
decency here about ass hoolishness and
disagreement so my college friends we
love to argue right and and no one
thought anyone was an [__] for it was
just for sports sometimes we'd realize
we're not even disagreeing on something
and that would be disappointing we'd be
like oh I think we agree and it was kind
of like sad it was like oh well there
goes the fun
and one of the members of this group has
this she brought her new boyfriend to
one of our like Hangouts and there was
like a heated heated debate you know
just just one of our typical things and
afterwards you know the next day he said
like is everything okay and she was like
what do you mean and he said like after
you know the fight and she was like what
fight and he was like you know the fight
last night and she was like and she had
to then she was like you mean like the
the arguing and he was like yeah and she
and so that's someone who is not used to
idea lab culture coming into it and
seeing it is like that was like this is
like are they still friends right and
ideal lab is nice for the people in them
because you're it individuals Thrive you
don't want to just conform that does it
makes you seem boring in an idea but you
want to be yourself you want to
challenge things you want to have a
unique brain so that's great and and you
also have people criticizing your ideas
which makes you smarter it doesn't
always feel good but you you become more
correct and smarter
an echo chamber is is the opposite where
it's not good for the people and it does
your learning skills atrophy
um and uh and I think it's boring but
the thing is they also have emergent
properties so the emergent property of
an ideal lab is like super intelligence
just you and me alone just the two of us
if we're working together on something
but we're being really
um grown up about it we're disagreeing
we're not you know no one's sensitive
about anything we're going to each find
flaws in the other one's arguments that
you wouldn't have found on your own and
we're going to have a piffy double the
epiphanies right so it's almost like the
two of us together is like as smart as
1.5 it's like 50 smarter than either of
us alone right so you have this 1.5
intelligent kind of joint being that
we've made now bring the third person in
fourth person in right you see it starts
to scale up this is why science
institutions can discover relativity in
quantum mechanics and these things that
no individual human you know was going
to come up with without a ton of
collaboration because it's this giant
idea lab so it has an emergent property
of super intelligence an echo chamber is
the opposite where it has the emergent
property of
stupidity I mean has the emergent
property of a bunch of people all you
know you know paying field you know
fealty to this set of sacred ideas and
and um so you lose this magical thing
about language and humans which is
collaborative intelligence you lose it
it disappears
but there is that axis of decency which
is really interesting because you kind
of painted this picture of you and your
friends arguing really harshly but
underlying that
is a basic camaraderie respect there's
there's a
all kinds of mechanisms we humans have
constructed to communicate
like mutual respect or maybe communicate
that you're here for the idea lab
version of this totally it doesn't you
don't take it you don't get personal
right you're not getting personal you're
not
um you're not taking things personally
people are respected in an idea lab and
ideas are disrespected and there's a way
ways to signal that so like for with
friends you've already done the
signaling you've already established a
relationship the interesting thing is
online I think you have to do some of
that work I mean to me the sort of uh
steel Manning the other side or no uh
having empathy and hearing out being
able to basically repeat the argument
the other person is making before you
and showing like respect to that
argument I could see how you could think
that before you make a counter argument
there's just a bunch of
ways to communicate that you're here not
to uh do kind of what is it low rung you
know [__] talking mockery derision but
are actually here ultimately to discover
the truth and the space of ideas and the
tension of those ideas and I I think
it's uh
I think that's a skill that we're all
learning as a civilization of how to do
that kind of communication effectively
because I think disagreement as I'm
learning on the Internet it's actually a
really tricky skill like high effort
High decency disagreement like I
listened to uh there's a really good
debate podcast uh intelligence Square
and like they they can go pretty hard in
the paint it's a classic idea lab
exactly but like how do we map that to
social media when people like will say
um
will say well like Lex or anybody you're
not you hate disagreement you you want
to censor disagreement no
um I love intelligent Square type of
disagreement that's fun you want to
reduce [__] and for me personally I
don't want to reduce [__] if you know
I kind of like [__] or it's like fun
in many ways but the problem is when the
[__] shows up to the party they make
it less fun for the for the party that's
there for the idea lab and the other
people especially the quiet voices at
the back of the room they leave and so
all you're left is was with [__]
well that Twitter political Twitter to
me is one of those parties it's a big
party where a few [__] have really
sent a lot of the quiet
thinkers away yeah
um and and so so if you think about this
graph again
what
the what Twi some place like Twitter
um a great way to get followers is to be
an [__] with a certain you know
pumping a certain ideology you'll get a
huge amount of followers and for those
followers and the followers you're gonna
get the people who would like you know
not the people who like you
are probably going to be people who are
really thinking with their primitive
mind because they're seeing your your
being you're being an [__] but
because you agree with them they love
you and they think they don't see any
problem with how you're being yeah they
don't see the [__] this is a
fascinating thing people because look
because look at the thing on the right
agreement and decency are the same yeah
so if you're in that mindset the bigger
the [__] the better if you're
agreeing with me you're my man I love
what you're saying yes show them right
and the algorithm helps those people
does those people do great on the
algorithm